hello everyone
and welcome to today's webinar human
pluripotent stem cells
as a model for neurodevelopment toxicity
i am michelle ashton of labyrinths and
i'll be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth
and brought to you by gitco by thermo
fisher scientific
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
claudia miranda
post doctoral research fellow claudia
you may not be in your presentation
thank you for the kind introduction so
i'm proud to be part of the cell culture
hero series and i would like to thank
isco and thermo fisher for inviting me
to present my research
i would also like to thank lauren
chelsea taylor and michelle
for all their arrangements to make this
webinar a success
my name is claudia miranda and i am
currently a postdoctoral researcher
at the institute for bioengineering and
biosciences
at institute superior techniques my
research is focused on developing novel
human purpose stem cell derives
neuroprogenitors
towards the assessment of potential
neurodevelopmental toxicity
under 3d conditions
just a brief outline of today's session
so
first of all i would like to welcome all
of you
to portugal to meet our lab and to tell
you a little something about me
then i will move on towards a scale-out
approach towards the neural induction of
human industrial
pluripotent stem cells either for
neurodevelopmental toxicity studies
or as a model of prenatal exposure to
cannabinoids
then we will move on to final remarks
and some future work
and also for the acknowledgement section
so welcome to portugal the country where
i was born
raised and where i am currently working
in
portugal is located in on the western
continental side of europe
right near spain although we are a small
country in terms of life
we have an immense immense variety of
landscapes so
ranging from the snowy mountains in the
center of the country
to our seven hills capital city lisbon
we also have beautiful landscapes in the
north
filled with mountains where we have lots
of vineyards
as well as on the plains in el endezu
we have beautiful beaches on the south
in algarve
and lots of monuments to visit including
castles
and palaces and lots of history since
portugal
is one of the oldest countries in europe
we have porto home of the world-renowned
port wine
and we are a very proud country
especially concerning sports
and we are currently the european soccer
champions
i'm currently working at the institute
for bioengineering and biosciences which
is located
in institut superior technical the
largest
and most reputed school of engineering
science and technology in portugal
and also a part of university of lisbon
technico has three campy the main one
at the heart of lisbon in alameda ctn
technological and nuclear campus and
tigerspark where our lab is located
so just to tell you a little something
about me and my journey
i first completed my degree in
biochemistry
where i worked with human leukemia cells
and decided then to do a masters in
biotechnology
at technical where i fell in love with
stem cells
since then i did my phd at ibb working
on the establishment of platforms for
scale-ups
of neural induction of human purpose and
stem cells
and i have been a postdoctoral
researcher at ibb ist
since 2016.
so here's a quick pick of my work group
at ibb
which is called the stem cell
engineering research group
and without further ado i will move on
to present my research
so my research is based on the use of
human purpose stem cells
so these cells are very special so they
can be
differentiated into virtually any type
of cell within the human body
and they have the ability to self-renew
so these cells can be derived from from
two main sources
we have the embryonic stem cells which
are derived from the inner cell mass of
the blastocyst
and we have the induced pluripotent stem
cells or ips cells
these cells are reaper are somatic cells
that are reprogrammed back to a
pluripotent stem state
like so the main advantage of using
ips cells when comparing with embryonic
stem cells
is that we would not have the ethical
concerns that are
often associated with embryonic stem
cells
due to the destruction of a potential
human life
also ips cells give us the ability
to do disease modeling in vitro as they
can derive patient-specific cells
and then culture them in the lab to see
how the disease progresses
we can also use them for drug-istic
efficacy testing
for drug safety and in the future we
hope to use them for
organ replacement therapy but before we
can do any of this
we still need to have large numbers of
cells
and we need to obtain pure populations
of the cells that we desire
and in order to do this in vitro we have
three main platforms that are used
for the culture of the cells the first
one and the most classical approach
is the monolayer where we have cells
attached to a surface which is coated
with an extracellular matrix
so this system provides a defined
substrate for cellular attachment
and allows a uniform application of
external stimuli however since the
surface area available may be
too low we would we would end up with
low cell yields and this can be
surpassed by using microcarriers
so microcarriers are small particles
that can be coated with ecm
that provide us scalability by providing
large surface areas for cells to adhere
to
we may have some troubles in here
because the cells may have low addition
to the microcarriers
and there isn't a high cost associated
since for using the cells
we would end up with higher costs in the
downstream processing because we need to
separate the cells from the micro
carriers in order to be able to use them
and to surpass this we have steroids or
3d
aggregates which are the ones that i
work with
so in here instead of having the cells
attached to a surface
the cells are actually attached to each
other
providing a 3d structure and
like this we are able to better mimic
the individual environment
and since we are not dependent on the
surface
that cells need to adhere to we may have
high cell yields comparing with the
other systems
and as we do not have to use micro
carriers or
icm the process ends up being more cost
efficient however we need to
take in mind uh that may be some size
limitations
because we need to consider that if the
aggregates get
too big which is around more than 300 to
400 micrometers in diameter
there may be necrotic centers
in the aggregates where the gas transfer
and the nutrients
do not reach so we need to take care of
that
and the great thing about the cells is
that in vitro
we can virtually derive the cells into
any type of cell within the human body
and to do this we modulate the signaling
pathways
to to to direct cells to the lineage
that we desire so we can end up with
cardiomyocytes
with neuroprogenitors or even insulin
producing cells
in this case i'm going to try and force
myself to go
towards the neural progenitor state
as i mentioned so i used aggregates to
to do this process and free free
floating aggregates
uh often have one another problem is
that
they tend to agglomerate if they are not
under the right conditions and
in order to prevent this we can use
micro wealth
so in this microwave we are preventing
the aggregate from agglomerating
uh at the same time we can also um
define a specific cell number that we
want to have in each aggregate and it
has also been demonstrated
that the spatial confinements can
regulate early commitment steps
of human purpose and stem cells by
accumulation of endogenous factors
so and to derive the cells towards the
neural lineage
we used a very widely used protocol
which is called this dual smud
inhibition protocol
and basically it uses uh the culture
median
n2b27 and two small molecules to
modulate
pathways the fb and ldn and during the
first 12 days
of this differentiation protocol we
maintain the cells
in the microwave so here
you can see how the cells look like so
at day zero
we have an aggregate that's around 150
micrometers inside
and by day 9 12 we can see that
the aggregates rule but at the same time
instead of
being homogeneous we have some darker
zones that may
uh indicate that we have different types
of cells within our aggregates
also by analyzing aggregates at day 12
we can see that we have expression for
nesting and neural marker and
that we have low to no expression of the
oxford potency marker which
indicates that our protocol is efficient
towards the induction of neural
progenitors
from human circles and stem cells so and
we took advantage of this platform
to try and assess if we could use it
towards neurodevelopmental toxicity
studies
and in this case in particular we use it
to study the effect
of valproic acid or vpa so vpa
is an anti-epileptic agent used for
treatment of neurological diseases
however
it has to be very careful uh
when prescribing this medication because
it may interfere in the formation
of the neural tube so during pregnancy
there may
be risks of reduced cognitive functions
malformations development delays and
autism related behavior in the status it
may also lead to microcephaly which
is basically the baby being born with a
smaller head size
and in order to assess this effect in
vitro
we use the dual smart inhibition
protocol we maintain the cells inside
the microwave for the first 12 days
and during the initial period of the
neural induction the first
nine days we incubated the cells with
different concentrations of vaporic acid
and the first result that we got is that
with a range from
control conditions to one millimolar of
vaporic acid
uh we can see that uh when we have
one millimolar almost all of the cells
are dead
and that we have a decreased aggregate
diameter at day
12 uh just a little for .3 millimolar
but
uh more than half of the
diameter of the control when we are
looking at the 0.5 millimolar
concentration so this may be
one of the first results that uh may uh
comply with the
the microcephaly repo reports
also another way that we had to assess
if the cells were following the correct
differentiation pathway was to take a
look at the neural cell adhesion
molecule
or ncam during neurospecification
so this marker is virtually non-existent
in pluripotent stem cells but its
expression
increases as we are going towards the
neuroprogenitors and then
increases again as we are obtaining
neurons
so and by taking a look at the graphic
we can see
that in every condition we have
less enchant positive cells during
neural induction either at day 12
or day 19 when comparing to control
conditions so we have alterations in
this marker
which may indicate if we have a
prevalence of neural progenitors versus
neuronal differentiation so we needed to
assess this further
so we next assessed uh the neural resets
which are the
in vitro counterpart of the neural tube
so we first looked at number of neural
rosettes
and what we can see in the first graph
is that using 0.5 millimolar
of vpa actually significantly
increases the number of rosettes per
million cells when comparing with
control conditions
which is in line with the results that
the cells are not following the correct
differentiation pathway we also assessed
another parameter
which was not a number but the radiality
of the rosettes
so for this we did the difference
between the geometrical
center of the rosette and the center um
the physics center of the rosettes and
in here you can see in the pictures on
the right that under control conditions
they have beautiful
rosettes with the the centers uh right
in the in the center and we have a
disruption
of the location of the the center in the
pictures as
we go towards the point three and point
five millimolar
of epa so we have alterations
even in the neural rosette number
and also in its structure which may lead
in the future
to more problems of on the neural
differentiation
we also assessed by real-time tcr
analysis
neural markers such as pac-6 and
supplement and also plural potency
markers
as such as op4 and anox and the first
thing that we are able to see here
is that we have enough regulation of fox
1
especially on 0.5 millimolar of vpa
so on the other hand if we take a look
of the
pictures we can see that the exposure to
vpa
leads to a delay in the formation of map
to positive
dendrite networks where we
we can observe them at day 75 in the
control but we can only observe
the map to marker at day 125
either at 0.3 and 0.5 millimolar vpa
so by gathering these results
and especially the the subs1
um expression we can see and hypothesize
that instead of the cells going from
over that form
and following the normal neuronal
differentiation
to our generating neurons we have
a stabilization of sox1 and it has been
already demonstrated
that cells that have a software knockout
have been shown to exit from a
neuroprogenitor state
faster than wildfire cells so this high
expression
of fox1 in the cells exposed to 0.5
millimolar vpa when comparing to control
conditions
may be arresting the cells in a
neuroprogenitor state
instead of of differentiating at a
normal rate
so this complies with the results that
uh were obtained for the microcephaly
because
um we have less neurons so the brain
will not grow
as much so this was the first
uh platform that we used for for
studying
the neurodevelopmental toxicity
but we also wanted to go
for a very hot topic which
is uh the use of cannabinoids
and uh
there has been an increased usage of
cannabis and cannabis derivatives in the
last few years
either for recreational purposes or
for medicinal and so long
it around 113 different cannabinoids
have been isolated
the so-called phyto cannabinoids
so cbd for example
is the non-psychotropic substance
and delta 9 thc
is the primary psychoactic components in
cannabis
so in phytocannabinoids such as delta
9 thc or just thc can bind to the
endocannabinoid system receptors which
regulate
a variety of physiological processes in
the human body
such as synaptic activity in the central
nervous system
and analgesic and metabolic effects in
the peripheric
nervous system and recently
synthetic cannabinoids have been
developed based on the structure
of thc such as for example
thj018 or thj
and also eg018 or
eg as we will call it
the cannabinoid receptors cb1 and cd2
are expressed in the developing brain
and there is growing evidence supporting
the role of these receptors
in neuroprogenitor peripheral
proliferation
and modulation of neuronal maturation
and specification
and also the expression of these
receptors in the fetal
and adult brain was also reported
so prenatal exposure to cannabinoids
acting as
agonists of cb1 or cb2 receptors
can produce long-lasting effects on the
indocannabinoid system
and this signaling will affect
motor activity verbal development
nociception
and also drug seeking behavior among
other processes
and also due to to their lipophilic
nature
phytocannabinoids can easily permeate
cellular membranes
passing from drug consuming mothers
bloodstream
into fetal tissues so and how do they
work
so cb1 sorry cbd
binds to cb1 and also has a negative
allosteric
modulation of cb2 receptor
on the other hand thc binds to cb2
and acts as a partial agonist
also synthetic cannabinoids acts
as a full agonist of cb2 receptors
and they provide stronger and
long-lasting effects
on brain cells which are often
associated with more severe side effects
and also intoxications however the
cellular mechanisms underlying
cannabinoid effects on
human neural development are still
poorly known
thurs there is an urgent need for a
better
understanding of the impacts of these
substances on human brain development
especially due to to the contemporary
trends
of increasing cannabis use
so for this research we used a similar
initial approach as we did with
vpa and the cell work cultured inside
microwave for the first 12 days
the main difference was in the period of
incubation with cannabinoids which was
from day 19
to days 56. we used concentrations
of 10 micromolar for every cannabinoid
including cbd
which we had to reduce to one micromolar
since the cell did not survive
the endpoint analysis were mainly
immunofluorescence
gene expression analysis and single cell
calcium imaging
so the first result that we obtained was
that
by day 30 all six conditions
shows expression of progenitor marker
pac-6
and also neuron specific mach 2
protein interestingly
thc eg and thj treated cultures
showed decreased staining for the pac-6
neural rivet marker
which suggests a possible decrease of
progenitor pull
and exit for differentiation so to
quantify better
this effect we performed immunostaining
for
hux c d protein marker
that is expressed earlier in
differentiating cns neurons
and we counted the percentage of
positive cells
so our data show that the decrease in
the pac-6 staining
is accompanied by the trend for an
increased percentage of
ucd uh cells
positive cells upon exposure to all
cannabinoids
in parallel all cb uh treated cultures
exhibited elevated levels of apoptosis
marker clipped cathode
tree together these results indicate
that both thc and the two synthetic
cannabinoids
lead to perimeter differentiation of
rosette progenitors
that seems to be more pronounced
indicates of thj
possibly due to lower neuronal survival
upon exposure to thc and eg
and one of the reasons for lower
neuronal survival could be a functional
impairment or inability to achieve
functional
maturation
we next questioned if these neurons were
able to achieve
functional maturation and for this all
cells were maintained
in urinal maturation medium up to day 56
with continuous exposure to cannabinoids
immunofluorescent staining for mature
synaptic protein
seen of thc and treat itself
reveals decreased staining intensity
suggesting a lower density of mature
synaptic function
additionally an increase in gsap
staining
was also visible in both conditions for
the
the synthetic cannabinoids which
indicates a premature
bile differentiation in these conditions
to further evaluate both the neuron glia
ratio and the functionality of these
sculptures we performed
single cell calcium imaging
controlled and cannabinoid treated
cultures cells
were sequentially stimulated by exposure
to potassium chloride
and histamine differentiated function in
functional neurons are expected to open
voltage-sensitive calcium channels in
response to potassium chloride
which results in a massive influx of
calcium to the cytoplasm
on the other hand immature neurons
neuroprogenitors and glio cells
express functional histamine receptors
which
stimulation also increases intracellular
calcium concentration
then the histamine potassium chloride
ratio
can then be used to evaluate the
proportion
of mature and immature neurons in these
sculptures
upon potassium chloride stimulation
there is a sharp increase
in cytosolic calcium concentration
observed
in both controls and also in cbd-treated
cultures
with an average full change of
ferocities fluorescence
intensity around two in all three
conditions
in contrast very few cells responded to
histamine in this sculpture
and the few responding cells exhibited
full change below
1.5 indicating that most of the cells in
these sculptures
are excitable neurons with just a small
proportion
of neural progenitors and or glia
these results also agree with the very
rare occasional gfcp
staining which was detected in both
control
cultures at this stage
then moving on to cbd exposure to
cbt has a small but statistically
significant effect
on the functionality of differentiation
differentiating
neural cells with a lower amplitude of
response to potassium fluoride
stimulation
when comparing with the controls in
contrast
the exposure to both thc and the two
synthetic cannabinoids severely
impaired the ability to differentiate
neurons to respond to both
potassium chloride and histamine
so delta hc the delta nine hc3 itself
showed delayed response to potassium
fluoride
and has the majority of these responding
cells either responded too
late or were unable to return to
baseline
intracellular calcium levels it is
impossible to determine the exact
proportion
of cells that responded to histamine
therefore
the higher proportion of histamine
responding cells
most probably correspond to a mixture of
functionally impaired neuronal cells
showing abnormal response to potassium
fluoride stimulation
and with some glial like gfp positive
cells that are
also more abundant in this condition
and in comparison to thc thj
has a slightly slightly less severe
effect
on the functionality of neuronal cells
where there is a
less pronounced delay in the response to
potassium chloride
so the percentage here is similar to the
controls
but the the cells are still unable to
return to baseline levels after washout
of potassium chloride containing medium
the percentage of histamine responding
cells in this condition
is even higher than thc reaching
around 100 percent of all s itself
again this response is most probably the
results
of the functionally impaired neurons
with very slow kinetics
rather than of neuroprogenitors or
immature neurons
that uh express both uh
voltage-gated calcium and isomine
receptors
so finally eg treated cells
represent the most severely affected
condition
with no discernible peak of potassium
chloride response
and also the highest percentage of cells
with weak or no response to potassium
chloride
like the thj treated cells there is a
continuous increase
in intracellular calcium
that was also observed so this data
might indicate that
exposure to eg018 leads to an even
greater delay in the cellular response
to protecting chloride stimulation this
conclusion is further supported by the
absence of a well-defined act
of histamine response despite the
abundance of gfip positive cells in this
condition
lastly we also did a real-time pcr
analysis
and we used the ethanol condition to
normalize
all of the results and in here the most
pronounced flow changes of expression
levels were detected for the genes
including
the cannabinoid receptors 1 and 2 which
are the cn
1r and the cn2r and
exposure to both cbd thc and eg
and at the last extent led to a
significant increase in the expression
levels
of cn2r
it also interestingly the levels of the
the cannabinoid one receptor were
slightly increased
after exposure to thc and to the
two synthetic cannabinoids by days 30
and decreased by day 56 probably
reflecting the long-term down regulation
of cb1 levels which is similar to what
was reported to occur
at both protein and mrna level
in the response to chronic exposure to
thc
however both synthetic cannabinoids and
in particular thj
were able to elicit a stronger effect
than thc
curiously thj thj
and cbd which were found to cause less
functional impairments on neuronal cells
according to the data that i showed
about the single cell
calcium imaging they led to more
pronounced changes in gene expression
levels in both neural markers and cb
receptor genes
thus the effect of exposure to these two
substances
requires further examinations by
different techniques that we use
in this study so we can note the nature
of the cellular response
to these substances so in conclusion our
data show
that continuous exposure to thc and also
to synthetic cannabinoids
can induce functional impairments to
newborn neurons during the formation of
the human
central nervous system which is able to
produce
a deep and lasting impact on the overall
brain structure
and function
so we just we will just uh
uh go through a quick overview of what
we talked about here today
so first the spatial confinement using
micro
wealth is very advantageous
and it promotes accumulation of
endogenous factors
while avoiding aggregates agglomeration
and these microless can be used as a
scale out approach
to generate neuroprogenitors from human
purpose and stem cells
also we saw that vulpric acid has a
negative effect
on neural development through the
deregulation of
normal urinal differentiation and also
that prenatal exposure to cannabinoids
namely
thc and the synthetic cannabinoids that
we studied
promotes precocious neural and glial
differentiation
as well as abnor abnormal functional
of voltage-gated calcium channels
i would like to end up with some
acknowledgement so first of all
to my team uh at technico and
that they provided for the studies for
to my research group
that um is just amazing
and also for funding from sct and
aggie's niche
and lastly but not least uh to terminal
fisher scientific
for all the amazing uh webinar series
that
uh are currently um presenting
so thank you all for for your attention
and i hope that you have some questions
for me thank you
thank you claudia for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you'd like to ask
please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
all right let's go ahead and get started
first question is can this methodology
be applied
to different types of differentiation
protocols
from human pluripotent stem cells
hi so uh it can so and
we also have been applying this protocol
uh using the the same microwave that we
use in here
we use it towards the cardiac
differentiation and we are now starting
to
to have uh some data on the effect
of cardiotoxic drugs and we
hope that to share them share the data
with you
soon
great thank you okay your next question
here
why is the exposure to valproic acid
and cannabinoids at different time
points
okay so in these two cases we were
looking at different things so
in the first one with valproic acid we
were looking
at the effect on the on the neural
development
so we wanted to to assess
the usage of the epa during pregnancy
and to do so we incubated the cells
during the first
steps of the differentiation which is
from day 0
to day 9 and in the case of cannabinoids
we were actually looking to
to see the effect of of these molecules
on the receptors so we only inhibited
the cell from day
19 to day 56 because we wanted to make
sure
that at least some some cells were
already
expressing the receptors in order to
to the cannabinoids to have some effect
on the on the cells
and that's why we incubated the cells at
different time points
okay great thank you now is there any
reason to choose that range of
concentrations
of vaporic acid uh
in fact there is so when we were
studying
the the the effects of alpharic acid we
wanted to include a range
that included the physiological um
concentration
that uh occurs in the in the bloodstream
so
we used uh concentrations between 0.01
and 1 millimolar and the actual
physiological concentrations in the
blood
are around 0.3 to 0.5 millimolar
and interestingly those were the
concentrations in which we found
the negative effects of vpa on the
neural development
thank you next question will you be
using
microwells for single cell analysis
or do you prefer seeing cells in the
global context
okay so in this case uh we
we actually uh tested the cells um
using a global context uh uh because of
two things one before because it's
cheaper
and that was uh just one of the reasons
and i think it's interesting to have uh
if possible to always have a look at uh
everything so um not all of the cells
are equal and although it's also
interest
interesting to have a look at a single
cell analysis
and actually in the case of the cardiac
differentiation
we are uh going towards that
uh that area uh in this case we only
tested a global context so
but it would be interesting to have a
single cell analysis
to to see if the response to
a small population of cells within the
aggregate or in in
the in vivo case within the brain
is enough to promote the same response
uh
as if all of the cells were in the same
country or
were in the same condition so that would
be interesting and we are taking a look
uh
for that in the future
thank you so much claudia and do you
have any final comments for
our audience before we go today
yeah thank you uh first of all uh i
would like to
thank again to all of you that attended
this webinar today uh it was a pleasure
being uh here to and showing you our
research and
what what are we planning to do in the
future in
our lab and uh i hope that you that you
also apply
to to this program because i think it
brings
a lot um of attention and also
a lot of interaction uh with people from
different backgrounds
and um please feel free to
to reach me uh to to
to know a little more about our research
and so i can answer
more questions so thank you again for
attending this webinar
thank you claudia i'd also like to
introduce our gitco
cell culture heroes program manager
taylor thornton who will also provide
some final comments
hello everyone i hope you enjoyed
claudia's presentation
for the latest updates on upcoming gift
code cell culture heroes
webinars or to apply to become a hero
please visit our website at
[Music]
thermofisher.comcultureheroes
and follow our social media pages on
instagram and twitter
our handle on instagram is gibco
cellculture
and on twitter it is gibco thank you so
much for watching the webinar
and thank you again claudia and taylor
for your time today
we would also like to thank labruz and
our sponsor gitco by thermo fisher
scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
labyrints will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye
you